well for more than a year the only
espionage threat you've heard about is
Russia even though the worst thing
anyone's pinned on Vladimir Putin so far
is a handful of dopey Facebook ads that
almost nobody saw but it's because the
Russian threat is grotesquely overblown
doesn't mean that foreign spying isn't a
problem for us it definitely is a
problem
Chinese spying is the real problem China
is our main rival on the world stage the
Chinese government spies on us
relentlessly on our companies on our
military on our government hundreds of
thousands of Chinese nationals live in
the United States most of them are
harmless but some large number of them
are spies in March of 2016 for example a
Chinese national pleaded guilty to
helping hack the computer networks of
major defense contractors data related
to this c-17 strategic transport
aircraft and the f-35 fighter jet was
stolen and made its way back to China
and it's not the first time the Chinese
have stolen vital military secrets
they've done it a lot their industrial
espionage is if anything even more
aggressive earlier this year a Chinese
wind turbine company for example was
convicted of paying an engineer to steal
secrets from an American manufacturer
and to add insult to injury after
stealing the information that Chinese
company then canceled 800 million
dollars in contracts this is not
uncommon the US Trade Representative
estimates that the overall cost from
China's theft of American intellectual
property industrial secrets could reach
600 billion dollars every single year
that's almost as much as all annual
trade between this country and China
Chinese businesses are themselves a
front for more conventional espionage
since major Chinese companies are by
definition closely intertwined with the
Communist Party and the Chinese military
in many cases intelligence experts warn
that the Chinese mobile phone company
ZTE for example could easily begin
spying on any American who owns their
products were they allowed to expand
their share of the US market as they're
currently trying to do and those are
just cell phones
how about email and other electronic
communications well according to a
high-level government source who spoke
to us the Chinese government already has
direct or indirect control of much of
the architecture of our domestic
internet here in this country if China
wants to know what you're doing they
probably already can
how did that happen exactly how do we
get to this place
well slowly and intentionally on the
part of China
our leaders meanwhile we're not paying
attention to the Chinese threat some of
them knew about it but didn't care
they're getting very rich from China not
coincidentally some of these very same
people are the ones now telling you that
Russia is the biggest threat we face it
goes without saying that they're lying
and they know they're lying but what
they're really doing is trying to cover
their tracks bill Gertz has been
covering the threat from China longer
than almost any other American
journalist he's a senior editor at the
Washington free beacon and the author of
I war-worn piece in the information age
bill Gertz joins us tonight bill thanks
for coming on sure good to be here
so give us a sense if you can and I know
it's a complex topic but give us a sense
of the scale of Chinese spying on
American industries government in our
military sure it's a three pronged
threat you have traditional spying right
now in Alexandria there are two CIA X
CIA officers who are under investigation
or being prosecuted for spying related
activities in China then you have the
cyber threat and this is a massive theft
of technology from both the government
and the private sector and then last of
what they call the non-traditional
collectors that's the 350,000 Chinese
students here with researchers academics
and they're all working to gather as
much a secret government Chinese
government directed program to steal all
the most modern technology they're going
after the the cutting-edge stuff right
now artificial intelligence and quantum
computing so who's minding the store
who's protecting American industrial
secrets and military data well it's it's
the FBI's job to go after Chinese spies
just this week of bill Avenida the the
head of the counterintelligence unit
called the National Security and
counterintelligence Center said that not
enough has been done to deal with this
Chinese espionage and technology
collection threat and he basically
upgraded the threat during the Obama
period where they didn't go after this
at all now they he said it's a grave
threat
u.s. national security and it's
primarily in this economic sphere that
they're going after our secrets as well
as military technology as well so I mean
given that the Chinese economy is about
to surpass America's in size assuming it
hasn't already they are obviously our
main rival in the world stage why didn't
the Obama administration for eight years
respond to what is clearly the
preeminent threat we face well it's the
same thing with the Russia probe - they
knew about the Russia interference going
back to 2015 and did nothing so
basically it's been a passive approach
they rely on just diplomatic niceties
and they they basically ignored this
growing intelligence threat that as you
said is B the massive amounts have been
totaled between two hundred billion and
six hundred billion annually in our most
cutting-edge technologies well you would
think that American industry from this
data is being stolen would be
complaining in public but they're not no
they're not there was a meeting last
year with a lot of the tech chiefs with
Trump in the White House and basically
all of them said you've got to do
something to cut off this Chinese theft
of technology they're just pillaging
everything that the Silicon Valley has
and there's been literally nothing done
to try and stop that it's absolutely
terrifying very quickly do you think
almost rhetorical question but the
relentless focus on Russia hacking or
election whatever that means
does that detract from our awareness in
our ability to respond to China
absolutely I mean Russia does pose a
threat but it's a different level of a
threat I mean all you have to do is look
at the the two economies the Russian
economy is seven times smaller than the
Chinese economy so they're not as great
a threat as China and so it's really
important that the United States
government take action to stop Chinese
espionage yeah like tonight bill Gertz
thank you you've been reporting on this
for longer than most people have been
paying attention that's for sure
appreciate it